hello and welcome to another fundamental
investing through the use of python
programming in this tutorial we're going
to be putting everything together now
and finally incorporating where we just
were
with quandl and stock price with uh
our screener now so the first thing that
we
are what we're going to do basically
before we do it
instead of asking us like right now
we've got while true
raw input what stock do we want to apply
and then whatever we typed in
that's what was shown now what we want
to do is actually make it so
whatever the screener picks it will show
and only if that's what we wanted
because sometimes you know you might
want to run the screener without
um and just to generate a new array or
list
and you actually don't want to chart
everything so that's okay so we're going
to go ahead and work that in there as
well
so what we want to do is come to our
screener
the screening program that we made that
all it did was screen stocks
and the first thing that i'm going to do
is at least take just even better we'll
just take this one array you can take
all the arrays that you want
but i'm just going to take that array
copy and i'm just going to replace this
first of all each stalker right so
that's the first thing that we want to
do
and now because so what this what we'll
do is we'll loop through this
looking through the yahoo key stats and
find any that are exceptional
companies now uh the next thing that we
want to do
is really i would say
that's about that's about all we need to
do what we're going to want to do now is
is scroll down slightly into the actual
screening element
and we'll take this and we'll actually
put this
down below but first we'll take this
define yahoo key stats
and we really need to take this all the
way
really to this point here
so i would copy that and
come over here and below all of our
other functions
come down and we're going to paste this
function and it looks like we have a try
so we better
close this with an exception
oops failed in the screener i guess
i'll and instead of this being young
stats let's actually just call this
screener stock
and then what we're going to do is
basically if yes then what do we want to
do
well if the answer to that question is
yes then we would like to
graph data so
uh we'll come down here and we'll just
take this right here
cut that if show charts equals yes i
would say
try and accept here as well
e print filled to
graph
string e and then we'll come here
and we'll try to do graph data stock
now we need to throw in uh this uh
functionality there
and so if we go back to our screener
that we made we did make that
functionality
right at the top here so if show
or show charts equals raw input blah
blah blah so
copy that and we'll come down here
and before we do anything else we'll ask
that question
and now instead we we should we'll just
delete this
and the the loop that we're going to run
run now is for
each stock in
even better and that even better array
will run screener
and then each stock
and i believe that should be everything
there might be something we're missing
here
uh let's go look at that screener one
last time if
if it meets all those requirements
uh if okay so that should be
do everything we needed to do so let's
go ahead and run it
first question would you like to show
the financial data quandl charts
why of course run it afam
wants to pull up a fam sure enough pulls
up afam for the first uh
stock that met there are prerequisites
so here is that stock and you can see
the price obviously the volume rsi
the net income the revenue and if i move
this over
turn on capital cool so we'll close that
one didn't like it
um wasn't perfect for our tastes
now we got this a cost here
and this one uh
quite the nasty drop there from 45 all
the way down to
really under five that's quite quite
nasty
quite the rough drop there for them and
we can see their financials here
at least all the data that we have on
them and
uh this brings up the point where i'm
not positive that i would really want to
cut
uh this data away because sometimes it's
good to see like where you came from so
the more data the merrier anyways
and if you wanted to you know look at
purely your data you could always zoom
it in
so you know clear that out it's going to
continue looking through stocks
waiting now we've got annalee or nly
here
and we've got some more data on it and
really of all the ones so far
it looks like um more like a nly is
is the best buy so far that's not
financial advice by the way don't invest
because i said that
anyway um so anyways you get the point
it is screening the stocks and when it
finds a stock that
we're interested in it will chart it for
us
don't mind all that red i just canceled
it
it was started to give me a 404 because
i'm not using my uh
my auth token so anyway
so that's that's that so you could run
this against
uh even the russell 3000 and
you could get new new companies that
meet the requirements you graph it up
get the price
all that stuff so a pretty powerful app
that
now at this point if you made it all the
way through you've made it completely
yourself
um so it's completely customizable by
you
and so i i think it's a pretty useful
app to run through to decide on
companies that you want to go long in
so hopefully you guys have enjoyed uh
i might throw in another video to show
you guys how to trim that
data because it's not as easy as it was
to trim the data for the other variables
but i'm just not sure how many people
are even going to want to trim that
because i don't think you'd want to trim
that data you kind of want that
historical data
but anyway if enough people beg me i'll
probably upload that video too
so anyways hopefully this series has
been helpful or helpful to you guys
um as always thanks for watching thank
you for your support your subscriptions
and until next time